There's a couple mistakes when you're thinking about value proposition.
One is that what you're building might just be a feature of someone else's product.
You might have a good feature extension, but it might not be a business,
or it might be a business for about 9 months
till the incumbent just adds that in their next release.
As I said earlier, these prioritizations of pains and gains
sometimes helps you avoid the "it's nice to have" problem.
Sometimes it's very easy for founders to say, "Well, they all liked it."
Well, okay. What you really want is they didn't like it; they've got to have it.
In fact, they didn't let me leave until they let me use the prototype.
That's when you know you have a business.
It has to be something that people demand,
and there have to be enough of them to demand.
You might find, yeah, I found the 5 people in the entire world that love the product,
but that might not be a large enough market.